Hello!
Welcome back!
Master!
Lady!
Hello everybody!
Oha!
Why am I saying Oha?
I don't know anymore Hello Mint!
Hello!
It's not Oha Mint!
Oha!
Yay!
Alright, welcome back for 5 months.
Thank you, welcome guys.
Two!
Some Playstation demo discs.
Hold on, let me grab them.
I don't know where to put my controller.
One second, one second.
I see birthday.
Hold on, let me talk first.
I need to do like a hold on birthdays.
We need to be like, first 5 minutes of the stream.
Let me talk a little first.
Hold!
I have one...
Two...
Three...
Four...
Five...
Six...
Seven...
Eight...
Nine...
Ten!
I have ten...
Ten...
Ten demo discs.
That were given to me.
So many.
They're all from the old Playstation magazines.
So, we'll just...
I can't tell if these have been opened or not before.
Oh, some of them.
Maybe.
This one feels sealed.
This one feels sealed!
I can't tell.
Oh, no, maybe.
Oh, no, no.
I can't tell.
I can't tell!
So I feel that maybe...
You know, we might have a part 3 of this eventually.
Last time I did this, we had some funny demo discs that we did.
I can't stop thinking about the ants one.
So if you didn't watch... I say part 1.
It's just I did this before.
If you didn't see the first one that I did...
Yeah, go check it out.
Because we just went down memory lane.
Hopefully all of these work as well, because...
You know, they're all so old.
Oh, the bugs life!
Yeah, not ants.
Sorry, yeah.
Bugs life.
That was so funny.
Gamer, thank you for 10 months.
Ta... taco... taco... taco...
Toki beefs, thanks for 5 months.
Tidal wave, thanks for 2 months.
I believe I have a birthday.
To sing!
Wait, hold on one second.
Oh, there we go.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, Agent Heroic.
Happy birthday!
So...
I think I might just pick some of these randomly.
Though, there are some that I see and I'm like...
I kinda wanna do this one.
11 months already.
Um...
The movie Ants was created to compete against Bugs Life.
Oh!
Then I did a faux pas, I know.
I did something probably so scandalous.
Some of these discs have the game's...
Ah, that scared me.
On them.
Just gonna take you back to past.
Some of them don't have what games are on them.
Some of these...
Oh my god!
I haven't really looked at all of them.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh, so maybe I'll just do these randomly.
And of course, yes, there's Metal Gear in here.
Of course there's Metal Gear in here.
Actually, well, there's two.
But one's a game demo and one is not a game demo.
But there is one that I do want to do.
Which is the demo of Yakuza.
Which, I don't know, you might have seen it in the thumbnail.
But it's there.
Oh, there's a replay of here of Ape Escape.
We don't have Ape Escape.
Wow, there's the Metal Gear.
Wait, there's three Metal Gear.
Oh!
There's a replay of Ace Combat.
It's a replay.
No!
Oh my gosh, this is Lego.
Oh, I thought that said Five Nights at Freddy's.
I was going to be like, wow, they have Five Nights at Freddy's on PS2?
It was...
It's not Five Nights at Freddy's.
It's Fight Night Round 2.
Which I guess you could see, I saw something that starts with an F.
I saw Night.
And then I saw that the title was kind of long.
And then...
Interesting.
This one has only three games.
Whoever got this magazine got completely...
But it has portable ops video.
But they got completely scammed.
Okay, I'm just going to pick randomly then.
Fight Night at Freddy's Round 2.
Pretty much, pretty much.
I'm going to pick randomly.
Oh, wait, I also have a disc that is open.
I picked this one at random.
I don't...
Oh, there is something in here that I want to play.
I picked this one at random.
I'm going to put it in now.
Oh, oh my gosh.
It's all ripped up.
I'm checking the discs.
The discs actually seem in pretty good quality.
Like, pretty good shape.
Not a lot of scratches.
Yippee!
Okay, opening.
Closing.
Okay.
The scratches give them soul.
I don't...
I want them to work though.
Nice.
Their battle scars.
I'm also playing through OBS.
Okay.
He's so loud.
Because...
Guys, I'm so...
I'm feeling so icky today.
I'm so sorry.
What is this?
You guys rec...
Inaccessible.
What is this?
It's sexy.
It's sexy, whatever this is.
The Matrix!
This stream has not yet been rated.
Look at her go.
Oh!
Yuki, I saw your super chat.
I will sing, of course.
After this.
She looks like...
Akoto Kusanagi.
Ghost in the Shell.
What is this?
Oh, stolen.
Coming soon, you guys!
Coming soon!
Any day now.
It's doing this all on its own.
I'm not touching it.
My game is possessed.
It's my birthday tomorrow, but unfortunately I'll be busy and probably won't be able to watch the stream tomorrow.
I'll try to make it if I can.
In case, can you sing happy birthday today?
Of course, Yuki!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday, Yuki!
Happy birthday!
Alright, let's see what we got in here.
Playground.
Oh, was that...
Was that E.T.?
It won't let me go back.
Why is it like this?
It like automatically moves, but if I try...
It's fighting with me!
Stop!
I'm trying to see!
I can't tell.
Stop!
I don't think it's my controller.
Is it?
I don't think so.
It was my controller!
We're gonna have a good time, I think.
This is the one I wanted to play.
Every single one of these has to have a sport game.
What is Musashi Samurai Legend?
I'm so curious.
Let's try it.
Defend.
Run, walk, jump.
Katana.
Perform selected technique.
Lock on.
A bad sequel?
Oh, okay.
We're gonna try.
It's from Square Enix.
Let's see how it is.
There it is.
Square.
Square Enix.
Oh my god!
It is a hundred... Oh my god!
It's so... World ends with you!
So...
Oh my gosh!
I couldn't tell from the art before.
So... Wow!
Happy birthday!
Okay, Powder.
You got me right before I started the game.
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday Powder Girls!
Happy birthday!
I like how there is just no music.
No nothing.
What is this?
What are those pants?
That's Peek.
That's just a product of it's time.
Nebulium Tower.
V2!
What are the abs on this guy?
Oh my... Wow!
Wow!
That's all he said!
Even the interface looks very Kingdom Hearts.
The hair goes crazy.
I'm gonna kick and punch him off the thing.
I thought he would...
Oh I got money from him.
Excuse me!
Let's go.
There is so many of these guys.
There is so many of them.
And then also...
Let me know how the audio is.
Oh there is this thing too.
At least they are easy.
There is so many of them though.
They don't do anything.
Camera controls are...
Oh no they are not inverted.
I'm just stupid.
There is so many of them!
Please!
Wow, my reaction to a miss.
There is so many.
I'm just gonna run past them.
Oh god I'm gonna die in the demo.
Please!
I don't wanna fight all these guys.
There is so many.
What the hell are you?
Oh they look like that girl from...
From Darkstalkers.
At least we get a new enemy.
I can't see!
Fucking
claws.
They are really easy.
I
don't remember her name so you guys might be saying the right one, but I don't know.
Ouchie ouchie.
I don't know what's going on.
You guys said it's a sequel?
Give me all my cash money baby.
I don't know how to change what thing I'm doing.
Oh here we go.
Paralyzing palm, shooting star.
Let's try that one instead.
Do they stop ever?
What else we got?
Celestial strike.
It's a combat demo!
What if I keep going?
More of these guys.
OK.
Oh shoot.
The camera is kinda wacky.
OK we can make it through guys.
We are just gonna run past.
Oh god.
Wait.
They are just politely waiting for me.
Very nice.
Yeah.
Stupid.
This is like watching those hurdlers knocking each one over.
Look.
I was...
You know...
I was testing their...
They have a range of motion.
I was testing it.
Let's get in the elevator.
Thank you so much for the 10 gifts.
Thank you.
Pass that floor.
We are going to the roof.
This guy's pants.
Vaporoid.
Boss battle so soon.
Can I paralyze this guy?
I'm paralyzing you.
I shouldn't have wasted so much health.
I think.
I don't like the camera on this.
OK.
I don't think I should use this one.
Let's try the celestial strike.
What are you doing?
Please.
Time's up.
I thought
I died.
OK.
Coming 2005, everybody.
You can play this.
OK.
Guys, we have to play.
We have to play.
Wait.
Is Area 51 any good?
Is this one any fun?
I'm going to... Since I have so many discs...
It's not that I'm on a time limit or anything, but...
I don't feel 100% today.
I might do like 3 games.
2 or 3 games per disc.
We'll see how... What interesting ones we got, you know?
Why is L1 junk?
What?
Aim, move character.
L1 is...
I didn't press it yet.
It said clearly you do not want to play this game.
Grenade is previous weapon, next weapon.
I'm not going to remember any of this.
That's OK.
The FPS.
It looked like a FPS.
Look at the aliens!
Found footage.
What was that movie that did the ARG thing?
Oh lord.
Cloverfield.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Huh?
This guy looks like he's trying to become an alien.
Can you just speak up please?
I turned up the volume even.
PS1.
No, this is PS2.
But yeah, it still looks really, really good.
It looks really good.
Yeah, you're right.
Oh no!
Progress must take a step back.
Hasmat Team Delta responds to emergency calls at Area 51.
Oh, I can...OK, there we go.
The company that made this game doesn't exist anymore.
Really?
9 months of membership.
Thank you, Reese.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Wow.
It looks like Samus.
Samus suit.
You could say they were mid-way.
They never made it to the final destination.
They got stuck mid-way.
Oh no.
How do I...actually, how do I shoot with the gun?
I said X to use.
Maybe that...
Does X to use mean use the gun?
I didn't look up how to use the gun.
R1?
OK, OK.
Is he getting possessed?
Nah, he's dead.
Oh he's possessed!
It's voice activated like Lifeline.
God, please no.
Regular man.
Otaku.
What is this voice acting?
Alien pig!
OK, start with lies of the past.
OK, now it's louder.
Horrors.
Don't spoil it.
As we descended into this hell, my teammates were killed, one by one.
I escaped death, but in that fight for survival, I became infected.
I was changed.
As my powers grew, my humanity died.
In the end, I was left to complete this mission, alone.
I could have just kind of...
I didn't press anything.
OK.
Find the comm station and contact bridges.
OK, hold on.
Shoot.
Oh, that's...yeah.
Is there like a...OK.
What is this, actually?
Oh, OK.
It's not hold, it's a trigger.
OK.
Jump is...
And crouch.
And jump.
Oh gosh, I'm scared of the aliens.
I'm scared.
Look what's going on here.
It's absolute craziness.
Oh no, it's inverted controls.
OK, I definitely will mess that up.
I'm sorry, guys.
What's that?
Jacksfilms?
Who are you?
Let me in.
Oh, that's right.
That's reload.
Jump is this.
For some reason.
Jump.
OK.
Let's try this door.
Maybe use...
No.
Oh my gosh, a person on the moon.
Do they just have that on loop?
Press the button.
I'm trying.
I don't know.
I'm pressing X.
I am.
Press, press, press, press, press.
Check the front desk, maybe?
Oh yeah, maybe there's like a card key or something, right?
All the aliens are waiting for me.
Oh god, I hate inverted controls.
Door access.
I'm pressing X.
How do I X?
Oh, there we go.
I just had to look at it.
OK.
Shoot.
Sorry.
Oh god, hold on.
Please hold this controller.
That's why are you both shooting at me?
This is bad you guys.
This is bad.
Oh this is bad.
Invert controls.
I can't see anything.
I think I died.
I don't know actually.
I'm also going to turn off vibration.
Oh thank goodness.
Yes!
OK, we're so back.
We're so back, baby.
Alright.
Here we go.
They're going to come in and I'm going to start shooting them.
Nice.
I can't see with all this.
I'm just standing here and getting blasted.
I'm going to throw a grenade.
That's not a grenade.
This is a grenade.
Hello sir.
Oh god.
I think I'm done with this game.
Throw a grenade.
Oh we both threw at the same time.
Isn't that so romantic?
The screen shake is wild.
I can't see anything when I'm shooting for real.
Holy cow.
OK.
Thank you Area 51.
Wow, what a cover.
Wow.
Oh my goodness.
The real answers behind the crash at Rot...
OK, I was reading that.
Remember
the reviews of this game?
They said David Dukovny from the X-Files sounded really bored.
They were right.
Oh, that's him.
Alright guys.
The real game of today.
Oh, I know this one.
But we're going to play the Spongebob Squarepants movie demo.
Doomdiowee green man throw.
Oh, here we go.
Move menu cursor?
Move PC.
Paddy... I can control Spongebob Patrick.
Or the Paddy...
You can check Y's.
That would be cool, but no biggie.
Is it Ys or Ys?
I can't remember how it's pronounced.
The car in the movie.
Let's see how far we get through this and then we can maybe check it out.
Ease.
Yeah, OK.
I thought...
Spongebob... I imagine this is the first movie.
Oh my gosh.
It's pronounced Laurel.
I hear Yanny.
Yanny, Yanny, Yanny, Yanny.
Nick Games.
Actually, this week, it's so funny, I almost played that Nickelodeon Showdown game.
I wanted to play the... how do you... it's like, Not Smash.
I almost played that this week.
Nick All-Stars.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
How many...
Oh my goodness, how many intros are we getting?
Let's get it on.
Have you guys heard Spongebob recently?
Please, let my man rest.
His voice sounds so bad now.
Oh, it's so bad.
3000 miles to Shell City, sandwich driving 101, floating block... let's do the 3000 miles.
Like, I know some people's voices are going to change, especially with that kind of demanding type of voice, I feel.
Yeah, Tom Kenny, Tom Kenny, thank you.
But like, oh man, it sounds like he's just struggling.
It doesn't even sound like he's getting old, it just sounds like he's like...
kind of killed his...
Who is it talking to?
Who is talking to me?
Oh, the daughter!
It's the daughter of the king.
Yeah, yeah.
You have enough Goofy Goober Tokens, now I can teach you to use the Bash Moob.
Now I...
Oh, SpongeBob Gushajitama!
First triangle, now you can hit things directly above you.
I can't...
OK Oh no!
The desert?
I think that's not what you call that.
Why does he stick his finger up like that?
I'm the master now.
I'm crying,
this is so funny.
Oh, press R1.
Oh, this is Mindy.
This is... Hey Mindy.
I thought... I thought she didn't want to talk to us.
So true!
Oh god.
The camera...
Did you guys ever want to see SpongeBob's teeth?
Why are you walking like that?
Why is there like a drift?
SpongeBob please.
Wait, I think...
I think there is also inverted controls here.
No, no please.
No!
They all talk!
Is this really for the PS2?
Because the movie came out in 2015.
What?
No it didn't.
OK
Oh gosh, I thought the game crashed for a second.
He does his famous...
You like screwed up teeth, don't you Minto?
I actually unironically do.
It's my favorite thing.
Oh!
What's happening?
OK, we can get this guy up his butt.
Just kidding.
Yeah!
That should take care of him.
Oh, we gotta collect Krabby Patty things.
Dumbbells.
How do I just...OK.
Alright, let's go.
We are men.
Why did he say that?
I don't need a song.
I'll sing.
It's your birthday.
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Milk.
Happy birthday.
I don't remember that in the movie.
There are some more boxes.
Guys, look how...Hi Spongebob.
Hi Spongebob.
We are so close to him.
Wait, how am I supposed to get that one right there without dying?
That guy came at me so crazy like...
Oh yeah.
Nice.
Where is Patrick?
He was here and now he's gone.
Why does he have all this stuff?
Why does Clank have all this in his...
in his little...in his boxes?
Oh gosh, now there are two of them.
Ouch!
Hey, where are you?
What does that mean?
I can't see anything.
Please.
We are taking care of them.
Wow, this is a pretty...
Oh maybe I can jump on top of these.
Oh, I thought I was to destroy them.
Wait, the P means you have earned your first upgrade point.
Whenever you see the P, press select.
Did you guys see a P?
Wait, there are things.
Press to upgrade.
Are you sure you want this upgrade?
Yeah?
When upgraded, it allows Spongebob's Macho Karate Spin to reflect enemies' projectiles back at them.
Wow.
Hey, I thought I was supposed to be able to reflect your stuff back at you.
Something has been disconnecting from my computer today, so...
Just ignore.
Hopefully it's nothing.
What is that horrible sound?
I thought it was mine.
No, it's all me.
What's up there even?
The Chum Bucket doesn't serve Krabby Patties!
Not on my watch.
Oh my goodness.
Super Sponge!
Yeah!
You can only press this button by standing directly beneath it and pressing it.
What is that horrible sound?
Oh, is it this thing maybe?
How do I destroy it?
This thing.
Oh, this thing!
How convenient.
Peace and quiet.
Did I get all the stuff?
I think so.
What's that say?
Checkpoint?
What do you mean, checkpoint?
There's more?
Ouch.
We are so manly.
I bet if I jumped on those, I could find secret areas, but...
What?
You can even brainwash the jellyfish.
I know!
Ouch.
Yeah.
Demo secret areas.
Yeah, they are really important.
Who's throwing that at me?
Who was that?
Are you guys throwing stuff at me?
No.
They're so mean!
Oh, that's timed.
SpongeBob, don't drown!
SpongeBob, I can't see you!
Where are you?
My god, they don't stop laughing.
Like...
It sounds like they are joking on their own time.
What is this?
Come on, SpongeBob.
I need you to get up there.
Thank you, buddy.
Shut up!
Where do I go from here?
Oh gosh, I'm crying.
I can't concentrate!
They keep laughing at me!
How do I get to the other side?
Oh my gosh, I wish I could just tilt the camera down a little bit.
Shut up, please!
Please, shut up!
Oh my god!
I died!
Oh, good thing we had...
Oh, that's a headache waiting to happen.
Oh my god.
I missed him.
There we go.
They're still going!
My stomach hurts.
They just wouldn't shut up.
Why would you program them like that?
Now we wait.
Nice.
I
wouldn't do programming.
Oh my god, even Plankton... Everybody just doesn't shut up in this game.
Holy cow!
I need more health.
This
thing is respawning now, I see.
Come here!
Hey!
Bouncy bouncy task.
I think I'm good.
Shut up, please!
What did he say?
Oh, I died again.
I thought he just said that he's pregnant.
We're good on this.
Anyway.
There we go.
I'm done.
You guys are brainwashed!
You guys are brainwashed by the buckets.
You're brainwashed by the buckets.
Resist!
Checkpoint.
There's more?
How long is... This was only one of the missions, you guys.
This is such a long demo.
I
won't let you!
First ever super chat after my first trip to Japan.
The Japan episode helped me be way more prepared than I could have been.
Thanks for always post-firing.
Oh, genetic!
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
I'm glad I could help a little.
Oh we got... You're right!
We got a point!
Let's do the bash.
What do we do now?
Press the triangle to detonate the glove.
Wait, what do you mean?
Stick to things?
This is like the longest demo.
I guess that's what you want though from a demo, no?
This is...
We stick it right up his butt!
Nice.
Good job everybody.
Oh, I missed literally every single one of those.
Which way do I go?
Oh, that's it everybody.
We played the game.
We beat the game.
Time's up!
Get out!
Holy moly.
Maybe I should have done the Krabby Patty car.
Those guys laughing really killed me.
I think maybe I'll hold off on this one.
Just because I want to be able to play some of the other discs.
Let's play another disc.
Yeah.
I know that the series is pretty good though, right?
I've heard good things about it.
It's moving on it's own again.
Stop please.
I just picked a disc that... I didn't pick a random one.
I have one that doesn't have a sleeve.
It was like combined with another sleeve.
Oh wait, what if the... I don't remember which sleeve it was combined with though.
Actually, what if that one was the one that had what was written on the sleeve?
Now I don't know.
What?
Secret disc.
I don't know.
Yeah, this is real gotcha.
Oh I should be saying the last one we did was...
PlayStation Magazine issue 90.
We got baseball.
Get rekt!
We got a lot of baseball.
So that was the first disc.
How did it taste?
Have you guys ever licked one of the...
I feel like ever since they told everybody not to lick the Switch cartridges, everybody probably has licked it before now, right?
These demo discs introduced me and my brother to the best game of all time, Snake Eater.
I have that one, J-Rod.
I have it.
I have the Snake Eater one in here.
Right here.
You can't see it, but I'm looking at it right now.
What?
You haven't licked it.
You haven't licked the Switch.
Why is there so much baseball?
OK, I'm clicking out of it.
Issue 80.
We've got...
Track Gran Turismo 4.
OK, nevermind.
Let's go to the playground.
Playground.
You haven't tried it?
I got so curious because they said it tasted so bad.
And it did.
We have Tom Clancy's Rainbow Six 3.
Terminator 3 Redemption.
Fight Night 2004.
Fight Night at Freddy's.
Siphon Filter.
The Omega Strain.
Psy Girls.
Psy Ops.
Alias.
Hit... Wait a second.
One moment, please.
Please hold.
OK, no.
I have another game with Hitman.
I was wondering if that was the one that...
I have another disc with Hitman.
All-Star Baseball.
iToy Tech Demos.
And that's it.
What do you guys wanna...
What are we... What are we in the mood for?
Peace Combat with Psy Ops.
This one.
Mindgate Conspiracy.
Psy Girls.
OK, we can do Psy Ops and Psy Girls.
Here's your man, Nick Scryer.
Facial reconstruction and a memory wipe.
Intelligence has the movement attacking the refinery in about 90 hours.
This memory wipe will give us plenty of time to drop him in...
Why do you sound like that?
His boobs are out.
Don't hug you too.
They dismissed General Krieger, but Scryer stayed with Mindgate and took his psychic powers to a new level.
Oh no!
Wow!
Remote viewing.
Mind control.
Telekinesis.
I can't read this fine.
Psy Girls.
That's an MGS bootleg by Konami.
Made for... Made on...
Made on the MGS Fox Engine.
By Konami's Yuuki.
Wait, what?
Psy Ops.
The Mindgate Conspiracy.
With my mind... Your mind is the ultimate weapon.
Oh, coming soon.
Oh, it's also midway.
Psy Ops is how I found out about one of my favorite bands, Cold.
What a nostalgia trip.
Oh, it was just a video.
No!
Try Psy Girls.
Here we go.
We can play this one.
Hide.
Evade.
Movement.
Jump.
Action.
Reload.
Main weapon.
Attack.
Secondary weapon.
I'm not going to remember any of these.
We got Psy Girls, baby.
Yeah, it was just a trailer.
Did it say that it was just a trailer?
Okay.
Konami.
Twice.
Nice.
Yeah.
This is viewable and playable.
Ah, okay, okay.
I thought the viewable was something else.
Oh, yeah.
I saw a cheek!
This looks really good.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, yeah!
Psy Girls.
Oh my god, it's so stretched.
Might be my resolution.
That might be my fault.
You can selected her.
Oh, sorry.
Sorry.
It's not... It's... It's me.
I read it wrong.
I thought it was saying you can select a girl.
You selected her.
No, I didn't.
Asuka is not available.
We have to go with ice.
Ice, ice, baby.
I will free camera it.
Thank you.
Ice, ice, baby.
You can selected her.
No!
I don't know where I got the can from.
I just inserted it with my brain.
Your mind is the greatest weapon.
Hello?
It's just loading guys.
It's just loading.
Hello?
Uh-oh.
It might have died.
I think it died.
Well, this disc didn't have so much good stuff.
I think maybe so.
My Yoshi does all the peak streams.
Yeah, I guess we...
Oh,
this one is actually pretty scuffed up.
I didn't check it beforehand.
Thank you.
Playstation Magazine issue 80 demo disc.
Thank you for nothing.
Let's see.
I'm going to pick...
Let's pick another one at random.
You can't selected her.
John Cena.
Where is John?
Why we have John Cena?
Okay, I'm picking one at random and it's...
This one!
This one has something I wanted to see.
Wait, this one doesn't feel like it's been opened.
It barely has any scratches on it at all.
It's beauty.
Yeah, we got a nice fresh one.
I'm going to need you guys to choose what game we...
There are some replay stuff in here, but we can't...
Replay is only if you have the game, no?
Extra special.
There is a hidden demo in this.
How do we get it?
How do we get the hidden demo?
So we have here Playstation Magazine issue disc 105.
Let's go to...
Why?
I think this is just a video, no?
Sometimes these are pretty funny.
Belkan War
Belkan War We've awakened Nan.
Nice game in this game.
I think this is just a trailer.
I think it's just like a...
But I kind of like the behind the scenes stuff.
Calm down.
Shoot down all enemy bombers.
Don't let them get close.
Come on baby.
Sneak!
My favorite elegant.
I want to play.
Dog fights!
New features.
Yes, the trilogy stream win.
I definitely have Ace Combat.
We will play Ace Combat this year.
Oh no.
It's so jarring hearing this commentary over something I remember is so intense.
It's so chill.
A CEO.
His glasses are so small.
Now, there are dog fights and then there are dog fights.
You have to change your inflection buddy for that to make sense.
Dog fights.
Now there are dog fights and then there are dog fights.
AI before AI.
I know.
Dog fights.
You have to change your perspective for playing.
Press R3.
That's it.
Good luck.
There are no controls.
I can't play here.
But thank you.
Tell me that later.
It's me!
How old is this?
Versus?
It's probably not online though.
2006?
2004?
Mid 2000.
I think it said 2006.
Salmon Ping?
What?
I'm confused.
Wait, what?
Huh?
Please show me a cutscene right now.
I need to see a cutscene right now.
I want to play but there is no online.
Use real actors?
I need to see it.
I can't wait to play.
He said it!
Hey buddy, you still alive?
He said the thing!
Nice That was a good video.
What else we got in here?
Siphon Filter.
Rampage.
These are all videos.
Then we have extras.
Which are the credits.
But also...
So what we can play is Hitman Blood Money.
Mark Echoes Getting Up.
Stimbot Chronicles.
I like how this looks already.
MLB06.
Neo Contra.
Oh Neo Contra.
OK.
Maximo vs.
Army of Zin.
R-Type Final.
Real World Golf?
I kind of want to play that.
Sorry, I pressed it so fast.
I pressed it so fast.
Somewhere in the Western United States.
That's close enough.
Kill the lights and radio.
I can't read it.
It's so...
Rex.
We'll approach.
Oh, it's so fast.
We'll launch a one man STV.
That's him.
Don't worry, that suit represents the latest advance...
We had new tropics...
Oh yes, the nanomachines!
I know this dialogue!
I know...
Sorry.
Liquid.
Bang, bang, bang!
It's the best part of the comic.
Liquid.
The comic is going too fast and it's out of order.
Behind me!
Sniper Wolf.
Oh Vulcan Raven.
Bye bye.
Working title.
Did you guys get that?
Did you guys get all that?
Come over and play these old school games with me.
Yeah, let's have a party.
I'm gonna do an Ace Combat reference.
Tomorrow is my birthday.
A victory sure would be nice.
But it's not actually your birthday, is it?
We got Sleep Coden.
This is also a video though.
Oh wait, Hitman Blood Money is a video.
I'm just one peace walker.
Should we try Neo Contra?
It is your birthday tomorrow.
Oh my gosh, dad!
Should we wait for tomorrow?
Do it.
This is Contra hard.
Use a weapon.
Oh use a lock on weapon.
Switch weapon.
How do I use?
Oh use equip standard weapon.
Nah, I've never played Contra before.
I've never played it.
It's hard core.
Nah, not even the old ones.
Thank you so much for the 5 gifted.
Thank you.
AD 4... That's a spooky number.
I'm gonna be busy tomorrow.
I'll do it now after the cutscene.
Oh my god!
Dinosaurs!
Bill Rizzler.
Jaguar.
Wait, this is awesome.
That's sick.
Was this song in DDR?
I feel like it should be.
Look at their legs.
Or 2DX or something.
2DX is Konami, right?
Am I crazy?
Adrenaline pumping action.
When do I get to play?
It said it was a demo.
We get the full song.
Pretty ladies.
My eyes.
No!
He said it!
Mr. Contra!
It's still going.
Do we get to play the game?
I don't care.
I didn't want to say it, but you guys said it.
That was awesome!
OK.
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday dear Non!
Happy birthday!
A demo with two players.
I should have maybe done the tutorial.
Type 1.
Charge shot.
Spread shot.
Let's do the machine gun.
Oh my god!
This is insane.
Oh my gosh, the bloom.
The bloom is crazy.
I hide like a ghost you are.
How do I shoot?
Wait, I was shooting.
My dinosaur!
There it is.
OK, switch to...
Oh, this is the machine gun.
OK, here we go.
Bye!
Run little lizard!
There is like a third weapon.
Maybe that?
What did I just do?
Oh, I think that locks...
Ah, I see.
I see, I see, I see.
Nice.
I don't know if I'm hitting him or not, but...
What the hell are you?
Stop throwing your cargo.
Let's go.
This
is kind of fun.
I see how this works.
Kind of.
Yeah!
You are going down buddy!
How do you deal with post Japan depression?
I don't know.
How do I deal with my normal depression?
I think I got to crawl.
I think I got to go.
I think I got to get out of here.
What am I doing here?
Is it going to blow up that guy?
I think I just got to keep running though.
I'm a little confused.
Oh, I died.
Nevermind.
I'm just going to keep going up.
More rockets?
Maybe.
What the
hell is this thing?
The music is so casual.
Nice.
Please, Mr. John Contra.
There we go.
Nice, nice, nice.
He's got that doki bird now.
I'm learning!
D for...
Damn!
D
for degrees?
I don't think we're getting any degrees.
Are there any other things?
I kind of want to see real world golf.
Is that OK?
That looks like a real man.
Like green screened in.
Golf.
It's not a real man.
There's a lot happening here.
Wait, it's a real world... That is a real man!
They turned up the brightness to 100.
He has no feet.
Revolutionary...
Put every aspect of your swing into the game.
It's so high technology.
Ten stunning 18-hole golf courses.
Championship mode, career mode.
Oh, he's judging.
Look at the booty.
If only golf was real.
Improve your game with video tutorials.
My eyes, every time they switch to this other screen.
Golf club for real golf action.
Cool!
Just swing to play.
God, they gave this guy a huge dumpy though.
On the green.
Most realistic and exciting golf game ever!
Wow!
I didn't realize it was a video.
It's the most... It's the bestest golf game there ever has existed!
Get in, stream it with 3D.
My new 3D is almost done actually.
Actually.
But I want to have a debut stream for it, so...
But I saw it yesterday.
I was like...
Wow!
It looks so good.
It looks so, so good.
Sheena!
Thank you for the raid!
Hello, hello everybody.
Hello, hello, hello.
Are we good with this disc?
Today we're going through...
Wait, do you guys want to watch the Hitman movie?
Today we're going through PlayStation Magazine demo discs.
R-Type please.
Oh, where is R-Type?
Oh, R-Type Final.
What is this?
I
can't argue about the realism, but it's not Neo Turf Masters.
We'll just... We got this.
Yeah, maybe we'll do golfing.
Maybe we'll do... What's it called?
I got to get whatever that thing was.
This game is currently under development.
Oh, minor problems?
I hope there's no problems.
That was...
Real world golf.
I got to get the thing for it too.
Oh, I can't read that.
Irem software?
It's so... Oh my gosh.
R-Type Final.
It's so bright.
Invisible Moose!
Thank you so much for the 10 gifts!
Oh no!
The people!
Everybody is dead.
What type of game is this?
Macross.
Shooting star.
It's a shmup!
Oh no.
I see.
I love all these intros.
These game intros.
Here, I'm going to pick out what disc we do next.
Just so that I'm ready.
I'm not looking.
There's so many!
That one is a little classic.
Shot a par in a tournament.
Some 4th grader hit an eagle and that's why I retired from exciting golfing.
Here we go!
I guess I'll just learn as we go.
Oh!
I thought eagle was a golf term.
I was like, like a turkey or...
You know in... Oh it is.
Why did you guys say poor bird?
Oh it's a high score.
Oh my...
I was like, damn that kid has the best aim ever.
He hit an eagle.
Let's go with the orange one.
He hit an eagle and an eagle.
You should watch Birdie Wing.
I know.
Birdie Wing was the hot stuff.
Basking in the summer sun, I greeted the seabirds.
But then I entered the demon's den.
Hi birds!
Bye birds!
I'm already killing it.
I'm already crazy.
Wait, what is that?
It's attached to my butt.
Oh my gosh, it's been so long since I played a shmup.
They're dumping their garbage on me.
I don't know why I'm playing with a...
I was playing with the D-pad.
I don't know why.
There's no music.
It's so quiet.
Thank you.
Are there like bombs or anything in this?
Can I bomb when there's an attack so that I get...
He didn't even get the...
He's doing unprecedented...
He's here!
OK, I got him.
And...
He
only shoots three times and then he...
I got him!
I'm zapping everywhere.
I'm hitting the wall.
I can't really...
There's nothing here.
That's me!
We have credits?
What?
Wait, I have to start over?
OK, thank goodness.
No, I lost all my power-ups.
I can get him back.
What the hell is this thing?
It's a crab!
It's so cute!
Maybe I should be up here.
Because I'm trying to throw these little bombs.
It's releasing its seed.
The fish eggs.
Eat
that.
Oh, I have a little special thing now.
Can I turn around?
It's so quiet.
Is this my thing?
Oh, this is my thing.
Now I have stuff that is hitting behind me.
So that's good.
How do I know what damage I'm doing to him?
It's here in the head.
Back up.
Back it up.
No, he's not dead.
Grab that guy.
I didn't see it coming out.
I think I'm good though.
I think I'm good.
I want to get to the next disc I think.
I like SHMUP.
Gosh, it's been a long time since I've played one though.
Let me put this one away.
Let's put this disc away.
Okay,
there was a birthday.
Hold on.
Oh gosh, there was so much happening and I was SHMUPing it up.
What did I miss?
Getting a new shoulder tomorrow.
Oh my gosh, good luck bandit!
Holy moly, whose birthday did I miss?
Poseidon!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Poseidon.
Happy birthday.
Okay, I picked our new disc.
I picked our new disc.
I'm excited for this one because of what's on the cover of it.
I hope we get another Bugs Life.
Please another Bugs Life situation.
And I restart.
Bugs Life was special.
Oh my gosh, it was so good.
That ending screen was worth every ounce of frustration that I got from that demo.
But it was so good.
What do we have on here?
Oh my gosh!
I just realized something else that's on here.
I'm so sorry everybody.
Your city is under attack!
We are on disc 106.
Real lighting.
Chaos reigns.
The burners...
R -Type's boss level features people having...
The people are wondering, you are Nick Mason.
Who are you?
You are Nick Mason.
T-Zero Enforcer.
Your mission.
What's your mission?
It's to take your city back.
How old are you?
Are you single?
The city needs a savior.
Urban Chaos.
In stores June 13th, 2006.
Wow, it will be 20 years old next year.
I wonder if that... Does that link still work?
urbanchaosgame.com 20 years.
Everybody, I'm so sorry.
I can't wait to play cars.
There it is.
Urban Chaos demo.
Pac-Man World Rally.
Medal of Honor Frontline.
Metal Gear Solid 3 Snake Eater.
Mercenaries.
Lightning Mint Queen.
Cold Winter.
Kill Switch.
There's a lot of gun games in this one.
Full Spectrum Warriors.
Guilty Gear Judgment.
This one is just a video though.
X3 the Official Game.
Also a video.
Urban Chaos Riot Response video.
Blade Dancer.
Anime?
Let's just get it out of the way.
OK guys, let's just get it out of the way.
I'm sorry.
Let's just get it out of the way.
I want to play cars though.
Pad Vibration.
To exit game.
Excuse me.
L1, L2, R1, R2, Start, Select.
OK, I have to press every button on my controller.
I know, I'm so curious how far we get to in the demo.
I'm so curious.
Yeah, we just do the reset code to get out of the game.
Trial version.
Even the music is different.
The demo that the Delta title screen is based on.
Are we going to witness the Halo jump?
X3 the movie, the game, the video.
Akio Otsuka?
Wait.
So wait, is it a Japanese dub?
I remember buying that Guilty Gear game when I was in college.
I feel sick.
Akio Otsuka.
I keep going.
No way!
Nihongo!
Ah!
Good!
Oh!
Is this a Stickmin reference?
Yeah, absolutely.
I like how this is just showing the opening cutscene.
The other ones all kind of showed cool videos.
I mean, this is the coolest video, but...
Oh my god, Halo jump.
Am I blocking the subtitles?
Sorry.
Stand up!
I'm moving to the rear.
The world's first Halo jump!
Be a bird!
Yeah!
Why
is he so stiff?
I imagine Delta will probably be able to choose Japanese with English subtitles.
So that would be really awesome.
Though I think I'll still probably stick with the dub.
It's like the rare times where I stick with the dub.
Oh, it is David Hayter.
It is 100%.
It's all the same.
They didn't even re-record it.
It's the original dub.
So...
He's in the changing room.
I love Akio Otsuka's voice, though!
He sounds so...
Thank you so much for the tag!
Thank you!
Colton, where would we...
I wonder how much of this video we're going to see.
Or how much of the intro.
I don't know what to do.
The entire
game is on the demo.
We get to play the whole thing!
I don't know.
I feel like maybe...
To Sokolov?
Is that too long?
I don't know.
Do the thing Snake!
Look up!
Look at me!
Wow, Russian Jungle.
This is so awesome.
Imagine playing this demo and you're just like...
It's so cinematic and...
Everything.
I can't get over it.
I sometimes am so jealous of people that got to play...
Got to play Metal Gear in their childhood.
I wish I had known about it forever now.
You're so thick.
It's Mint's husband.
Don't say that!
We're not married yet.
Not yet.
The interface!
We get to see all of Snake!
Oh my gosh, without the filter.
Sorry, I just pressed it.
I'm gonna skip through it though.
We know all this info.
Thank goodness.
You scared me!
Wait, what else?
We don't have our backpack yet.
Oh god!
Oh no!
It's the old camera.
Not yet, Mint.
Yeah, not yet.
Not yet.
Oopsie.
My bad.
Just started MGS3 and OMG it's so good!
Yeah!
It is!
Even the call sound sounds a little different, no?
I'm on it!
Why are you...stop!
Shut up!
Zero, I'm getting it.
Literally right now.
That's different.
Backpack.
OK, we know all this.
Oh wait.
Oh no!
I wanted to hear the voices.
My bad.
Sorry, I'm just gonna codec call them.
It's OK, I can...
Say the thing, Snake.
Does he throw up in this?
Oh, sorry.
I was like why is it...
Does it give me the option?
Oh R1.
There we go.
This is the most important thing.
Always check if he throws up.
It's always important to check if he throws up.
Oh no, I'm starting to do the...
He does!
Even in the demo!
Amazing!
They were like, this is very important.
So now in both demos that I've played of MGS3, he's thrown up.
Isn't that just so special?
Since I played the Delta demo.
And then...
Look at that crocodile.
Good night.
Come here crocodile.
Did I get him?
Is he asleep?
Crocodile.
I'm going to speedrun, or attempt to speedrun through this a little bit.
Any bug juice here?
Bug juice?
Hot dog!
Hot dog indeed!
Look at that.
Wait, can we see the snakes?
Look at them!
We can see Ariel.
Flash, thank you so much for the donut.
Thank you.
We got even like the Yabloko Malocos.
Our fruit.
Blah blah blah.
Yabloko Malocos.
Our fruit.
This cutscene.
I get to see his silly little grin.
Look at you!
I'm holding up my baby snake to the screen.
It's you!
Do you recognize yourself?
Oh, R1.
Sorry about that.
It's you!
No!
Oh my gosh, it scared me for a second.
It scared me!
The loading times in this are pretty rough, I'm not going to lie.
It looks like the codec is burned into my...
into my computer screen.
Sometimes it's scary.
I can barely see these guys because of how...
the quality.
There we go.
Do you think I can get him?
Maybe not from this far.
Hey mister!
There we go.
I can barely see you though.
You're so grainy.
Should we change our camouflage?
Oh, I did it again.
Nice shot.
Thanks.
Yeah, let's change.
Oh wow, we only have woodland paint.
Are there?
There is another guy.
They're not.
Thank you!
I saw that baby snake was being sold for 5.
I saw that!
Oh my gosh, the 5,000 yen baby snake.
Like, I saw that!
It was in...
That was your picture?
Oh.
Oh my gosh, he's scared.
No you didn't.
My bad.
I did the wrong button.
I was like...
I was shocked.
I was like, there's no way this costs this much.
Because I usually get them for like...
Most like 1,000 yen.
Wait a second.
Where's my...
You didn't...
You didn't do the smile!
No smirk!
Are you gonna...
No cutscene.
You think that guy is gone or...
Can't tell.
Let's just go.
If I get caught, I get caught.
Oh shoot!
No snake.
Go up.
Snake, please.
Easy.
Easy now.
I can never remember when there's a guy there or not.
You good?
Controller drift?
We didn't...
They probably were like, you're gonna have to get the full version for the special...
For the special smile.
In that part.
They really wanted you to know that the bees were there.
So they were like...
By the way, there's bees.
His voice is like smooth butter.
It's so good.
Yeah.
I want him to narrate everything for me.
Interesting that the English localization was already done but not the recording.
And it's like...
It's like the script and everything.
OK, bye bye.
It's like the script and everything too.
You think we'll get a meow?
I don't think it will go to that, no?
Just your imagination buddy.
Yeah, just your imagination.
Kinose!
Don't worry about it.
I'll leave him alone.
Oh, I did get him.
I did get him.
How funny.
Oh.
I think I would've just been the most excited ever to play this demo.
I recently got back from Ocean Deck.
I hope you got to see the Wisps leading the Ota Gate and went at it for nearly 5 hours straight.
Wait, what's Ocean Deck?
Let's go voice as Jigen in Modern Loop.
Stop, he does?
No, don't tell me that.
I love Jigen the most.
I should've never been taught that information.
I hear footsteps.
They're like so faint in my ear.
I think I can't tell if there's any guys because everything looks so crunchy.
I can't tell where any of the men are.
It's too crunchy.
I'm just standing here like a duck.
A standing duck.
Not a sitting duck.
Oh, there's a guy.
Damn it, stupid controller sensitivity.
The hand disappears so quickly.
Oh, there's a guy right there.
I see him, I see him.
I see him moving.
I was like, I know there's a guy in there.
Please.
I got him.
Don't notice me.
No one.
Crispy.
Yeah.
No, crispy.
Oh.
The guy's wearing pixel camo.
MGS3!
I heard him!
Oh my gosh, Ocelot sounds so similar to English.
Ocelot in Japanese sounds so similar to Ocelot in English.
My heart.
I wasn't even...
Let's play cars!
Oh, I got to hear Ocelot.
Let's play cars.
Brake, I don't need that.
Gas, reverse, steer...
Boost, power slide!
It's just like Mario Kart.
I lost gallons to you.
I hope you find it.
Of juice?
I want juice.
I want some apple juice.
Remember to do the transformer noise.
Transformer noise.
Orange juice.
Hello?
This is taking a long time to load.
The cars game is hefty.
Thank you, thank you.
Chu!
Did you know if you got the demo disc with Mitara Daisuki?
What is this making a joke of?
I know that's Mitara.
Is a fujo-oshi a fujoshi?
Or am I just doing the language wrong?
Mitara Daisuki.
Daisuki.
I like
How dare you.
How dare you make me tell lies.
Why is it still loading?
Hello?
Hold on, I'm checking my DMs real quick.
Why is this still loading?
We got the...
We even got the Pixar logo and everything.
It's a 4K game.
Hello?
Oh, oh, oh, I'm playing the game now.
What?
Strap it off the track.
Leave me alone.
I can't see anything.
It's so pixelated.
Power slide doesn't really work, I think.
Oh god, I'm drifting.
I'm drifting.
Oh my god.
He said it.
He said the ka-chow.
Oops.
You're okay.
I'm power sliding.
Wait, oh, through here?
Oops.
What is happening?
I'm drifting, I'm drifting.
Everything's so crunchy.
Safe driver, what does that mean?
Ka-chow.
I wonder where everyone else is.
I'm a safe driver, you guys.
Oh god, oh god.
I'm a safe driver.
Oh, ouch.
How am I supposed to...
Oh, they're right on my tail, I see them.
Ka-chow.
Can you guys hear it?
Should I turn it up some?
It is so bright and so crunchy.
I thought we would get a cutscene or something.
If this is the whole demo, I'm gonna cry.
Ugh.
Ka-chow.
I'm gonna boost just to make sure that they're wait...
I'm off track!
Oh no!
I'm still first, baby!
Oh, that's where my boost is from, okay.
Ka-chow.
That's all he says.
He goes, ooh, ow, and ka-chow.
Dang,
I beat Doc.
I beat his best even.
Ka-chow.
Next one.
No!
It took like...
I'm
disappointed right now.
What?
A Minto Ride to Hell Retribution Plate?
What is that?
I can't believe it!
We got more of a Bug's Life than this.
Why are there so many racing games on this one?
What the heck?
The loading screen was totally meant to be like half the demo.
I might
choose another one now, guys.
I'm so disappointed.
The Guilty Gear one is just a video.
We can watch it.
We can watch Guilty Gear.
Here, I'll pick one while we're...
You are!
Fine, it's just B&Gs.
Two games in one.
Does this count as another game completed for your yearly tag?
This one!
I picked another disc.
Crunchy.
I know, it's so small too.
Like, it doesn't even take up the whole screen.
How can you even...
How can you even see?
Destroyed!
Okey-dokey.
Put our next disc in.
Might be the last disc.
That we do for today.
I still have... How many more do we have?
We still have...
1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
Oh, I didn't get to do Yakuza!
Okey, I'll do Yakuza next time.
Yakuza...
Or should I wait until...
We have...
This one also has a portable ops video.
Should we do Yakuza once I've played so I can compare.
Oh, I have two that have a Metal Gear portable ops video.
I'm an idiot.
Oh no!
He just shot that guy down!
So quiet.
Where the hood at?
Wait, am I gonna get...
I don't hear any music.
I'm gonna get a copy!
I'm gonna get a YouTube...
DMCA!
Break the law!
Break the frame rate!
It's urban insanity!
Oh my god, the frame rate is insane.
16 players online?
What?
Oh my god, no wonder.
Oh my god, that guy was flying in the air.
Where the hood at?
Where the hood?
25 to life.
Spring 2005.
Let's see.
Let's see, we got PSP.
Hot shots girls!
And cute girls.
Showing off PSP.
Wait, what is it?
Tell me all about the PSP.
Oh.
Wow.
They put him on the screen.
They feel very comfortable.
Because it is very close to PlayStation controller.
Do you guys feel comfortable?
The steering wheel is a very important part of the car.
So we keep that kind of feeling when we design the PSP.
Hot shot girls!
PSP.
Everybody check your...if you have a PSP, check it.
Make sure the battery hasn't exploded.
Everybody check your PSP's today.
If you haven't already.
Now we are talking a huge chunk of memory at your disposal.
It's called UMD and it's the optical storage format for the PSP.
Oh, a place to plow.
Wow, she just...can I have that disc?
Did she just kiss that disc?
She just kissed it.
I got the PSP for the AKB48 dating sim.
1 out of 48.
So I could date my Oshi.
I dated her.
Yeah, I dated her.
We were totally going steady.
Yeah, no big deal.
Yeah, I dated an idol.
No big deal.
Yeah.
I dated her and then I dated Nene and Love Plus at the same time.
I had two girlfriends at the same time.
No big deal.
Wifi!
Is that Tom Cruise?
Tom Cruise.
They just cloned that guy.
It's Snake and Liquid.
They're clones of each other.
You can connect PS2 or PC through USB connections.
You can download some data from PS2.
So if you play a PS2 game, when you have to go out, you can check out the data through the PSP.
And then you can continue the game on the PSP.
What was that thing transferring?
Now add in other options with peripherals.
The PSP is also a communicator and locator.
Make sure you check yours.
Peripherals such as the headset with a microphone.
So you can chat if the game supports the chat function.
Really?
That's crazy.
I didn't know it could do that.
A toy type of game will be available.
And also with the USB GPS, new mobile entertainment will be created.
Oh my gosh, I have my Walkman right here.
On my desk actually.
I got it out of my old car so that I could update it with new music.
With such a versatile future facing product, Masajitani obviously excels at multitasking.
He has to juggle future concepts with practical methods of production.
It's very exciting.
There are a lot of challenges we need to overcome.
Where was that?
Was that like TGS or something?
It is very exciting experiences to create something new with the new desktop.
You have a Walkman?
Yeah, I do.
It will also be exciting for those who pick up the PSP to live a surprising new lifestyle.
Akihabara!
That was Akihabara!
Oh my gosh, I know that was right in front of the UNO Den building I think.
Maybe.
It actually depends on...maybe it wasn't.
I don't know.
Depends on which side of the bridge you're on.
Akihabara...
Sorry!
I clapped when I saw it!
Oh, poops!
It was poops!
Oh, it was Acid.
Just kidding.
Yeah, because he had the...what's it called?
Not poops.
It was Solid Snake.
My bad.
I got excited.
I don't want to play Acid though.
Acid scares me.
What do we got on here?
We got Madagascar!
We got stolen.
Oh!
Wait, we literally watched the video for that earlier!
We got juiced.
We got Delta Force Black Hawk down.
We got Fight...Five Nights at Fight Night Round 2.
We got Lego Star Wars!
We got Star Wars Battlefront.
Which I think I remember playing this demo as a kid.
MX versus ATB Unleashed.
Mobile Suit Gundam versus Zeta Gundam.
But this is just a video unfortunately.
We got Destroy All Humans.
25 alive.
Dynasty Warriors 5!
PS2 Cordless Controller.
Full Sail...
Real World Education.
What is this?
It's a school.
Let's find out.
It's a video.
I want to do what I love for a living.
I want to make documentary films that can change the world.
I want my life to be about music and everything music.
Change the way people use the web.
Start with the biggest artist on the planet.
Create robots and spaceships and aliens.
Create the ultimate fighting game.
Animate.
Direct.
Mix, mix, mix.
Games.
Movie.
Music.
Who teaches that?
Where can I learn that?
Full Sail.
Real World Education.
Wow!
That was...
That's where I want to be.
That was a...
That was a commercial.
Wow!
What should we do?
I want to play Madagascar.
Jump, talk, special.
There's two specials.
This is going to be great.
Madagascar.
Wow!
PSA, if you attended Full Sail University and took out loans to do so, you may be entitled to discharge of those loans.
Wait, what?
Did the school go under?
Oh, start button.
Back to the beach.
You guys, I'm getting...
I'm getting...
I'm getting Bugs Life vibes from this already.
It was a scam!
It was for profit.
Put a sock in it.
Where is the music?
There is no sound effects or anything.
Really?
Wait, why does he sound so familiar?
Good news and bad news.
They taped WWE NXT?
What?
Why does he sound so familiar?
How about we get this beacon together first?
He's not Frogbird.
It doesn't sound like Frogbird.
Switch players.
Oh, we can...
Why can't I be the lion?
What's wrong with him?
What does this guy look like?
Go get him, tiger.
Oh, he's so tall.
Okay.
He just growled at her.
I don't recall a warthog in Madagascar.
I have a confession.
I've never watched Madagascar before.
That's my confession.
What's this?
Giraffe.
Oh my god!
They dug his grave!
Guys, that was his special?
Okay, he has two specials.
He can do this.
Or he can do this.
Oh god!
He also does that.
Sorry!
Do these count as the parts?
Or am I getting...
My stomach hurts so bad!
Oh god!
Oh shit!
What
are the peppers for?
Why can't I eat them?
Oh holy moly.
Can I go after this guy?
Oh god!
I'm in literal tears, you guys.
I can't!
Holy cow!
I can't...I'm crying.
What do you want?
Oh my god!
He's so small!
I can't...
Oh my god!
Wait, what did I do wrong?
What did I do wrong?
Charge!
Wait, what am I doing wrong?
Maybe this button.
Use...
Okay, okay.
We gotta aim.
Okay.
Okay, too far.
Too soft.
Wait, these guys are dead!
I can see their little ear pockets!
I can't
stop crying.
I can't look at him.
He's dead.
What do I do?
Oops, wait.
Oh no, I killed it.
I can't stop laughing.
Oh my god!
Oh shit, I did it again!
No, I just barely made it.
Oh no!
Wait, it's so hard to get in the middle.
Oh god, they are really dying!
I can't.
I can't play anymore!
He looked like he died though.
That second guy did not look like he made it.
Oh no!
Oh yeah!
He did make it.
First try!
Wait, are all their little lemur bodies littered in the ground?
Okay, no, they are gone.
Did we hold a proper burial for them?
Oh gosh, you guys.
I'm okay.
I'm cool.
I'm calm.
And I'm collected.
What is this?
Oh, you got a thing.
Press spin to pay respects.
It says here giraffe.
Like what do you want me to do?
Is this how speedrunners...
Is this how people speedrun the game?
It shouldn't be this funny.
It really...
Leave.
Cow.
Oh god.
Spin to win.
Can we get on this?
Nice!
Only a trained professional should attempt this kind of risky stunts.
I got it!
What did I just hear?
Oh no!
I got you!
I'm coming!
Wait, hold on.
I got to turn around.
I'm coming!
I think I can only talk to him.
Speedrun's trapped.
Is the crab involved in the job?
Do you need...OK.
Where is the switch?
We got to see what everybody else's specials are.
Where is it?
Where is the...that can change characters.
Where is the little totem thing?
Oh there is one.
Oh gosh.
Oh she also spins but like...
Here I go!
Oh damn!
She also...
Get me out of here.
I'm scared.
Oh there is like signs that point to which character does what.
She is too big to jump.
She is so fast.
We already got 4 out of 10 you guys.
We are killing it.
Can I go in here?
We are in the crock pit?
That doesn't seem very good.
I'm going to leave before anything bad happens.
We need to go talk to our little friend.
Well if you can squash enough of them in time, there is a piece of the rescue beacon in it for you.
As well as some quality face time with yours truly.
Oh my god!
Wait, how do I...how do I...oh shoot.
How do I...oh here it is.
How do I smash the crabs?
How do I do that?
I'm...ok.
Oh shoot.
What is the sound effect?
Holy cow!
He spent half of that time just laughing at Deadly Rage.
Guys, I don't think I have any...can we watch the Gundam video?
Yes we can.
I have no strength in me to do anything else.
I laughed myself silly.
I'm sorry I laughed so much at that.
I'm sorry.
I'm still crying.
I knew Madagascar wouldn't let us down.
I love the Disney games.
They're the best.
Oh wait, that's not Disney.
That's Dreamworks.
I love the shovelware games.
They're the best.
The sounds are so awesome.
Oh, that's it.
That's all you get.
Holy cow.
Too much time killing lemurs.
I was...
I literally LMFAO'd you everybody.
It was so funny.
That was so, so funny.
Anyway.
Sorry, I'm looking at some messages from people.
This was so funny.
I hope you guys enjoyed...
more of the PlayStation demos.
I don't know when I'll do the next one.
I'll give it some time.
Maybe collect some more.
Who knows?
But...
That was so good.
I want to play the Madagascar one again.
Warthog was voiced by Steven Stanton.
What has he done?
Let's see.
Steven Stanton.
I've
heard his voice before in something.
Maybe not.
I hope you guys laughed as much as I did.
I hope it wasn't just me.
Thank you, TriPrincess.
Thank you for the stream.
Thank you.
Thank you guys.
This is so fun.
Oh yeah, there.
Video games.
Madagascar is Melman and Wilbur.
Does my man do games?
He hasn't done a game since 2022.
No!
Demo disc streams are always so good.
What a banger to end on, huh?
Codefushi!
Thank you so much for the 50k.
Thank you.
Hard to breathe.
Dude of YouTubers.
Thanks for watching.
Thanks for hanging out.
This stream is the best thing that happened to me the whole day.
I was just seeing the levers dead on the ground.
Are these demo discs on emulator?
No!
They're on official PS2.
Official hardware.
Yes, yes.
But yeah, we have still more demo discs so we'll do this again in the future.
And I hope you guys have a great day.
Have a good night.
And I will see you when I see you next.
I gotta get to bed soon.
Cause I gotta wake up early for a collab.
That... maybe I'll stream my POV.
I don't know yet.
I'm gonna make a thumbnail and I'll decide in the morning how tired I am.
Thanks for the fun stream.
Hope you feel better soon.
Thank you, Bakeme!
So the waiting room, if I do decide to stream my POV for that...
It's a... I've also never played the game before, Lockdown Protocol, so...
I'm kind of nervous about everything.
But...
Hestia.
Hestia from Bishoujo.
JP, she invited me.
And it's a collab.
It's at 8AM, my time.
So it's early.
We'll see.
It's early time.
Have fun with K-san and Henyao.
Nah, I've never talked to K-san before so I'm nervous.
Yeah.
Spank!
Thanks for the 10 gift!
Basically, Hestia invited people that she knew could speak Japanese and English.
So it's like a JP-EN collab.
It's kind of interesting.
I don't know what we'll be speaking most.
Whether it's Japanese or English.
So...
That's kind of...
That's kind of why I got invited.
Hot dog!
Not just you, Minto.
I was really cracking up.
Really looking forward to cracking up.
Oh yeah, and I cracked up.
I have not laughed that hard in so long.
Thank you, MadagascarGiraffe.
Kuso Nihongo.
Yeah, maybe.
That's another reason why I was nervous to stream it too.
Thank you so much for the fun stream, Minto.
I love you.
Thank you!
Thanks for the superchat, Cyberfishy!
Speedyfire, thank you so much for the 5 gift ticket!
Thank you!
Gonna learn Japanese for the stream.
I don't know, I'm so nervous about it.
And it's early morning.
So if I do decide to stream at POV, the waiting room might even be up like 30 minutes before the stream.
Sorry for any... sorry if it's last minute.
Happy early birthday!
Otaminto, thanks for the nostalgia trip.
Thank you!
Otaminto!
Thank you, Swampclose.
Loved this game as a kid.
For a movie tie, it was very fun.
It reminds me so much of the...
The Emperor's New Groove game that I played.
I love Lockdown Protocol because as a traitor, you can just win by lying and hiding items.
I've never played it.
I don't know anything about it.
I know nothing.
I don't know if my Nihongo will work so early in the morning.
Go play Ace Combat and Monster Hunter.
Have fun!
Are you planning on reacting to the Nintendo Direct?
I don't think I will be able to.
I think it will overlap with the collab.
Unless the collab is like 2 hours.
Wait, what time is the Nintendo Direct?
I think it's 10 AM my time.
All that spinning is giving me Gedan bias.
10 AM EST.
If the collab is 2 hours, I will make a...
I will make a waiting... like a thumbnail just in case.
Maybe if the collab goes over...
Then obviously I can't.
But if it ends early-ish, then I will do a Direct.
And I'll have a waiting room just in case.
Or not a waiting room, a thumbnail.
So I can make a last minute waiting room.
But we'll see.
If we're having fun and having a good time, I'm not gonna, you know...
I'm not gonna...
I won't be able to sleep.
I'll be awake at that point.
We'll see though.
We'll see.
Yeah!
OK!
Thank you guys!
Otsumamito!
And I hope you guys have a good day, have a good night!
Thank you so much for watching!
Thanks for hanging out with me!
Otsumamito!
Itterasshai!
Bye bye!
Your laughs give me so much energy.
Thanks Shabir!
Thank you!
Bye bye!